[MUSIC]
First days of school are hard.
I get it, I've been there.
But my first in middle
school was different.
I was sitting on my desk,
feeling like an outsider at a new school,
when I heard someone rush towards me.
Hey, he said.
We're missing one for table tennis.
In Chinese it's ping pong.
So you in?
I ended up being surprised.
I don't know how to play ping pong.
It's okay, he said, we'll teach you.
So he dragged me to a game with he and
his friends, boys and girls, and
we had a really good time.
Now, full disclosure,
I still suck at ping pong.
But I remember the feeling of
warmth of feeling included,
welcomed into that new community.
The game brought me in.
Four years ago, another friend of mine
dragged me to another game with him.
It was at an old sports stadium
three hours away from Shanghai, and
it was pouring rain that day.
Come on, I said to him,
nobody is going to travel three
hours in this horrifying rain to
watch people play video games.
Plus, it's going to be awkward,
I'm definitely going to
be the only girl there.
Well, three hours later,
I was sitting at the stadium,
soaking wet and surprised to find
myself surrounded by over 10,000 fans.
They were young, they were excited,
their faces were painted 18 colors.
And I looked out to the crowd,
I was definitely not the only girl there.
In fact,
almost half of the audience was female.
When the game started, it was like
someone lit a fire in the stadium.
A dragon threw across the screen, and the
crowd broke into roaring waves of cheer.
I looked around at the people
high-fiving around me,
some were older, most were younger,
some were men, some were women.
And I felt well, the game, the video
game is bringing people together.
And that excited me.
For the following three years I co
founded an e-sports company in China,
aiming to create
experiences just like this.
To connect people through e-sports and
gaming.
Now, fast-forward a couple years,
last summer I moved to the US.
Now, I had heard about the difference
between the Eastern game culture and
the Western game culture.
Namely, here,
it's a little bit more boy-centric.
So I wanted to check it out myself.
I drove up north to Oakland Esports Arena,
to a game of Fortnite.
Fortnite is the massively
popular game here.
And it's one of the most
gender balanced game here.
It has over 46% of its player base female.
I wanted to find a few female gamers and
ask them about their experience.
When I got there, well,
this is not a 10,000 people arena,
and there were no dragons or
anything, but it was still very cool.
It was a cool hip arena with
state of art computers.
When I walked in the players and the fans
were glued to the screen immersed in their
game, and behind them was this big
screen showing what was going on.
They didn't notice me when I walked in.
But I noticed something.
I was the only female there.
And this is not a stand alone incident.
I've heard women on podcasts and articles
talking about experiences similar to mine.
Finding themselves to be one of
the very few females at Esports events.
But wait a minute, if the stats
are correct, the percentage of
female gamers here in the US, is actually
quite comparable to that in China.
In both countries,
almost half of the gamer base are female.
Then where are the US female gamers?
Maybe they just don't like offline events.
But then I realized,
it's not just offline.
The female gamers here are not
showing up to offline events.
And they're invisible online too.
My friend Claire tells
me about her experience.
Claire is an excellent Overwatch player.
She's been playing the game
since it launched.
And she tells me, that when she
plays Overwatch, She mutes her mic.
Why do you mute your mic?
I asked her.
Well, she said, because I don't
want them to find out I'm a woman.
What would happen if they
find out you're a woman?
What would they do to you?
For one thing, she said,
they would not invite me to the next game.
On the other hand, there is also
that awkward private messages.
Hey, how are you?
What are you doing?
What are you wearing?
Come on, I don't want any of that.
I just want to play my game.
There is an underlined assumption here
about the motivation of a female gamer.
Namely, if you can't
proof your authenticity,
if you can prove your gaming skills and
your love of gaming by beating every
single person out there that challenges,
then you don't really like gaming.
You're just doing it
to get guys attention.
Well, this reminds me of an old joke.
Which says, women go to colleges just to
get husbands, just to get Mrs degree.
Now, that joke is over half a century old,
but we're here in 2020 and gaming is new.
It's no longer that small niche
industry in the 60s and 70s.
It's now a giant industry
overtaking the entertainment forum.
The global gaming
industry is $120 billion.
It's bigger than the global movie box
office and the music industry combined.
2.5 billion people around
the world are gamers.
So it's now a big community,
got a big voice.
And what kind of messages
are we saying with this voice?
Then I realized there's also a second
layer of the issue, a less noticeable one.
In 2015,
there was this incident called GamerGate,
in which online trolls attacked female
video game producers with rape threats and
death threats,
demanding them to get out of the industry.
Brianna Wu, a female video game producer,
right at the center of GamerGate
reflected on her experience recently
in her Op-Ed on New York Times.
She said, I wish I could tell
you things have gone better
five years since the GamerGate,
but they haven't.
She said, we built worlds of fantasy for
men, by men.
For men, by men.
Now, the issue we're seeing here
in video games, it's not fresh.
We've seen it before.
We've seen it in Hollywood,
we've seen it in traditional sports,
we've seen it right
here in Silicon Valley.
But we have a unique window
of opportunity here.
The gaming industry, despite its rapid
growth is still growing, it's still small.
It will grow bigger.
It's growing to take even more
dominant part of our social life, and
not just our generation,
but generations to come.
We gotta do something here.
What can we do?
Well, I think three things to be done.
One, if you're a female gamer,
unmute your mic,
speak up because you deserve to be heard.
If you are a male gamer,
actually mute your mic.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Try this for a change.
When you go home tonight, sign on to
your favorite game and create a new ID,
a female ID, with a female name,
and see what happens to you,
and notice how you feel.
What you would like to be changed.
Two, if you're running a game company,
which I know some of you may go on to do,
think about who you're bringing
on to your creative staff.
Think about who you have
on your production team.
Because the digital world,
just like our real world,
should be created for
everyone by everyone, isn't it?
Three, if you are none of the above, well,
whatever your form of game play is,
Pokemon Go, Jenga,
Texas Hold'em, bring someone in,
invite someone, bring them in.
When I moved here last summer I brought
my tickets with me, a six year old and
a two year old.
I remember feeling very nervous
taking them to their first play date.
Would they make friends?
Would they be accepted?
because when they moved here,
they didn't speak a lick of English.
Will they be included?
Or would they be like their mother,
when I was their age,
where they just sit
silently in the corner?
When we got there the party
had already started,
the kids had laid out toys on the floor,
blocks, Lego and switch.
My kids jumped with joy and
immediately they rushed in, and
the children started playing the games,
brought them in.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]